The number one reason I think why
startups fail is disagreements occur
among cofounders.
So you really want to find someone that
you want to work with for the long haul.
Clearly you want someone you get along,
with that compliments you, but
I've seen a few things that
sometimes get overlooked.
One is the risk profile,
what does that mean?
It means if you're an entrepreneur and
your runway to go out there
without funding is 9 to 12 months.
You want to find a cofounder that
shares that same long longevity
without funding.
Because if your cofounder only has
three months to go without funding,
that will create a sticky
situation down the road.
So yes, look for those traits of getting
along, and wanting to work well, but
look at the risk profile as well.
Look at how long you and
your cofounders can go, and
be aligned with that before
you start the journey.